TO ADD TAJ PBLY
SAY.VER A GOOD
YOU S
TAE
SUBURBS.
ED LIV
CAYIV.
EDOUT THE STRIKES
ANW THEYE HIT.
>> Reporter: YOU REALLY FEEL,
JO STRIKES BY THE RUSSIANS
ARE ONGOING.
T  STRIKES  APPARENTLY THEY WER
WI 3SILES, NORMAY
THEY'RE HIGHLY INACCURATE D USE
ARES OF CIVILIESHIGH.
AT THE SAME TIME YOU S
RESILIENCE HERE ONHE
UKRAINN T SEE BEHIWA MASSIVE IA.
IT TOOK ONE DA PATCH ANGOING.
A GREAT PICTUR OUR
PRUC HIS INSTAGRED THAT OWHEN TT
HAPPENED, FIVE PEOPLN
,
UKRAINIAG WITH THE
OTHERD  AS TAKIE ELECTRICGRID,D
U
PLE TORVELECTRICIT
EC
>> VLADIMIR PUTIN SPNGENT.
DOIM TO RESPOND TO
WHAT PRESIDENT BIDEN SAIAB WIT?
E T RESPONWA OF THIS.
HE DEFINITELY WILL HAVN
, HEARD WHATBIDE
BECAUSE
RESPONDE AF N
DIRECT QUESTION FROM CNN A
THIS IE SPOKN SAYING,
UOTE, EVERY DAYS OF, THE N,RH
THRACTICE,
RUSSIA DOES NOT NT
EVERYTHING ON THE WEST WLEE
REAAT SIA USING TACTICAL > IN
ENT,YY, SUGGESTITHE DEATH  FROM
WOK.
ER OGROUNDNG ACTION LIKE
,  AMAZI O YOU SEE
ZEKY HIS
NIGHTLY ADDRESS.
THIS G THERE WERE 28  WHICH 20
ONRI SHOWEARMBATDRONOS DOWN.
EXCELLENT SKILLSHUE PE
LIVES.
THANK YOU FOR THAT
M THE NUMBER LAUNCHED RAWN IS RE
MISSILES AN
DRONES.
BS
THESARE SOME OF TH
IMPRESSIVE WEAPONSHA
RAE AND I'LL G
SOVIET ERA THEY'VE AKIA, IT
HAS A  46 MILES, HITS
THINP TO 82,000
AT PIECE IN THE N ARSENAL.
THINAT THEY HAVE
IS SE'ABOUT A
IT HAS A RANGE O
HOLDS SIX ROCKET A IS IMPORTANT
NO OF WHAT THE UKRAINIANS
THIS IS THSKYYD HERE, A LIG
USED OR R BEINUSED TO  OUT A MIH
PARTICARASE.
AND THIS IS SOMETHIN TEANES.
CAPABLE OFS A STINR GOES UP TO
CAN DONGE OF 8,200 T
T MISSILE APON T
LEEN CALNG
EAPONS FROM ST
COUNATTACKS.
TO SOLDIERS. S WHAT IS ERO
OE SYSTEMS EN ROUTE
NASAMS.
IT PROTECTE E
AND OTHER AREA
WASHINGTON.'SNEE THINGS
IN GERMA SENDI T SLM. PRO
PROVIDE SOME OF THE TYPES OFGS .
E ON KOREA, EMS MISSILE SYST.
SAME SYSTEM WO USED